it's that time of year again folks
Assassin's Creed a new one
it's called syndicate it's not that old
bullfrog game it's an assassin's Creed
game and we're here with Alexa ray Korea
who reviewed it for video games car he
did Josh Shaw who played it a little you
played it a little yeah the Morden me
mm-hmm
not as much as it likes it right you
played 75% 75% sync that's great
almost done there was 25% we let you
finish that review complete you gotta do
everything every collectible every got
to be a bit too much we wouldn't have
The Witcher 3 review up still but yeah
you completed the crap out of this game
I did at night at at 10:00 on
gamespot.com
let's first of all talk about the world
because this is something that I'm not a
huge fan of some of the elements of
gameplay but the world the the London
that they create was somebody used to
live there not in the 1860s or whatever
and it's incredible I really it's it's
true to life and really evocative of the
dog yeah that place I feel yeah it's
really beautiful I never use fast travel
I always use the route launcher to get
around because everything just looks
really good and there's like people
milling around and you can jump on the
top of carts and punch the drivers out
like GTA like there's just so much to do
and like climbing this out of Big Ben is
really exhilarating how long were you
playing until you climb Big Ben I think
it's like in like the fourth or fifth
sequence where you actually have to go
up for it yeah excellent that was like
the first thing I did when I got to the
open world says like just sprint trivago
Square Big Ben you know I did as I ran
like I jumped from boat to boat to boat
that's pretty cool but it's funny
actually cuz I think points are like
masts and every yeah and sometimes
you're on like like boxes and a boat
just comes out of nowhere and just not
into the Thames yeah that's pretty solid
and yes were a pretty looking world and
let's talk about missions though second
of all I guess some of the let's talk
about the the side missions first of all
because in your review that seemed to be
one of the focal points of where some of
the best gameplay was happening oh yeah
I'm my favorite parts of the game where
the side missions with Charles Dickens
where you were ghost hunting you were in
his ghost Club doing some stuff about
town I really like the use of the
historical characters I think that they
fit in with the story really well they
fit in with
and setting really well and Jacob and
Evie's involvement with them I thought
was very smart it wasn't it didn't feel
shoehorned in but these missions like
the story missions get get get a little
creative and the conquering borough
missions you have the same in each
borough but these side missions are
really interesting like there's one
where you're you're hunting down a
printing press because Karl Marx is
having awful posters of himself posted
all over London so you have to find the
press and then rip down all the posters
and then tail the guy who's making them
and then interrogate him like why did
you do it and there's a lot of
kidnapping missions and one of the
missions there's a people are listening
to Karl Marx speak and you have to
infiltrate the crowd kidnap and by
kidnapping it's like you punch them out
and you just grab their arm for
different dudes that are maybe going to
kill Karl Marx okay and without
attracting any attention because if you
if you make a scene then someone shoots
Karl Marx and he ragdolls down and it's
like really really like awful but funny
Wow how many times did you watch comic
skits sure he's in the middle of his
speech he literally like rekt like just
rag dolls over himself which is actually
kind of funny but you have to escort
them very quietly out of the area right
and then kick them on their way and then
you come back and it's really
interesting I like to that variation so
that's aside stuff like you said there's
the main quests as well throughout the
game talk a little bit about the
Burroughs because if somebody hasn't
played the game they might not
understand what that is so there's a
bunch of different boroughs and kind of
like infamous ii saw and or crack down
or something like that like you
basically just complete those missions
to get control of those areas right yeah
each one has four different kinds of
mission bounty hunt Templars you have to
take down and one I'm forgetting right
now and then child liberation missions
were you free children from factories to
work for you to work to work for you you
can make them like pretty new plastic
items out of the front no it's so great
like I'll be walking down the street and
there'll be this little like chubby kid
like running by with an r1 over his head
and I go over and he's like hey neato
mom and he gives me like a bunch of
bullets and I'll be like wow this is the
London I wish I lived in it's so good
but yeah and and then there's the gang
war where you get into the gang fight
with the the gang leader yeah bro do
they got bigger because I was anyone but
I was like yeah I was like 10 versus oh
yeah the last gang fight I was in
were 18 people on both sides and like
the AI does a really good job of like
helping you out but obviously you have
to carry a little a little bit more of
the weight yeah it's like your thing and
then the King later comes out and you
one-on-one fight them really super cool
that's where those the the bombs that
electrocute people did you get those I
think Alexander Graham Bell gives them
to you
Bell gives them to you it's one of the
weapons that you can get from him and
you literally throw it on the ground and
it electrocutes everyone including
yourself so if you're willing to use it
you also take a little bit of damage
which is add so you know it's really
cool but no like you have to complete
all of those missions in order to and
then defeat the gang leader in order to
gain control of the borough and that
final gang war can actually be made
easier because if you kill the gang
leader earlier like sometimes you'll
complete like the third mission in the
area and the gang leader will show up
and be like screw you and if you and if
you if you manage to chase them down and
kill them then the rest of the borough
is so easy because I think leaders
already dead well we spoke a lot of
praises about London in terms of its
like architecture and how it looks and
everything but Josh we were talking
before about the sort of people in
London the actual pedestrians doesn't
really feel like sort of that you know
realistic open-world choices yeah it
doesn't feel as lived-in as some of the
like better more modern open-world games
because it's I mean I feel like the AI
is changed very little over the
Assassin's Creed history like the guards
still see you walking down the street
and like yell at you and chase you down
the people still kind of just like
they'll see a dead guard and just kind
of like look at it like yeah I'm playing
and they were like waiting for you to
move the body so you could get his cart
by yeah and it just like doesn't have
that kind of Grand Theft Auto like
everyone's got their own kind of
character and like some will fight you
and some will ignore you but like if you
kill someone in front of an NPC that NPC
will just not react they'll say stuff
but they aren't gonna fight you and they
aren't gonna run they'll just like react
yeah see I had NPCs run familiar when I
kill people in front of them I had
crowds actually dispersed away from me
while I was like murdering there were
missions where I'd like start a little
fight like a distraction and then the
crowd would kind of do a crowd thing
they'd all like rush past a barrier but
in just like day-to-day
like running around it didn't seem like
the NPCs were bidding I guess when that
stuff doesn't work it sticks out like a
sore thumb part of the time and but you
played a bunch of it I we got code like
feel like late last week and you played
a bunch over the weekend what was it
about it Josh that made you want to keep
playing it I do think I actually when I
first started I didn't think I'd like
the grappling hooks at all
yeah I thought it's like half the fun is
just like climbing the buildings but
those are like so exhilarating to use
there's like a lot of things you can do
just jumping off a building to
assassinate someone and then just like
going straight back up before the next
guy walks around the corner and like you
can also set up air assassinations by
making like a string across two
buildings and setting that up so there's
a lot of cool ESA's and just to get from
one place to another if you don't want
to ride the awful carriages yeah you can
just grapple your way all the way across
the city and so that thing actually
turned out to be really a really cool
way to traverse yeah and like you know
it's a nice that's probably one of the
biggest changes to me just compared to
previous games but as far as overall
like the thing that turns me off the
most is the stealth didn't feel super
tight and I wanted to stealth my way
through the game like all right do you
think Evie the most yeah me too me too
cuz she could fight it wasn't like she
was weak like she could totally take on
her share of people is just hers the
stealth sometimes it's like I feel like
I did it right but then I got caught and
like I tried again and I felt like I had
it and it just wasn't working yeah I
wasn't sure if I was my father the
system let's talk about the characters
then as well because to that point and I
guess that you have these two
protagonists and I guess later on the
game because you can sort of min/max one
of them on like stealth and the other
one on like brawling then you end up
having sort of almost like what happens
when you're in any other game we decide
I'll go stealth or go I go in like all
guns blazing this time you sort of God
you don't have to like yes write it
across the to think yeah they have each
of them has three just three skills
distinct to them and then the rest they
can learn everything and v's are stealth
based her stealth you can max out her
stealth stats she can carry more silent
weapons like throwing knives she can
carry like twice as many is Jacob can
and she has that chameleon skill which
makes her completely invisible if she
stays still which is really useful for
if you're like on rooftops and you're
like
waiting for someone you go invisible so
no one can see you even if they're
passing by Jacob has the more brawler
skills like I think my favorite of his
his personal skills is he it
automatically makes every counter shot
like if you counter with someone with a
gun they're instant headshots mm which
is pretty cool
handy tool to have handy tool to have
yeah we were talking earlier as well I
guess is sort of the the breath of
appreciation of certain Assassin's Creed
tiles is kind of all over the place
like there are some people who love
Black Flag there's some people who don't
like Black Flag some people who like
like the first one and don't and the
same is true of I feel like unity we
were all kind of on the same page about
it but the same is kind of true of
syndicate as well and one of the
elements that happens with that is how
much you sort of in like the protagonist
yes for me I'm not I don't think they've
kind of sparked as much interest as they
have for you but speak to that a little
bit who what is it about those
characters that you really enjoy so I
really like that I know with unity we
had the love interest and there was that
tension of like romance but jacob and
evie it's the way that they the way that
they've written them and the way that
they play them out like they're twins
but it's clear that like Evie was born
first when she takes it she takes the
the lead she's like we are doing the
assassins stuff by the book we're
looking for the piece of Eden like
please don't don't like like we're just
don't score anything up and he's just
like I'm gonna make a game like yeah
he's so excited about about his gang in
the first couple of cutscenes in the
game she's talking to Henry Green who is
the lead of the assassins in London and
she's like yep we're here looking for a
piece of Eden Annie and Jacob just pops
in and is like don't forget about my gay
like he's just so into it and I really
like the way that they play off of each
other she's very serious he's very goofy
they make fun of each other she's like
stop destroying things and he's like
you're uptight and I really like that I
really like that conflict like towards
the middle of the game it's very clear
that they have a very big conflict with
each other yeah
because of what each other has been
doing and they don't agree with each
other's methods but you know it all
comes back at the end about family and
stuff like that so I really liked having
that dynamic front-and-center rather
than a romance while rather than like
one guy just kind of swaggering his way
through the city which it was in the
early some of the early games but then
continue to be like consistently in
every single game yeah that's why I
didn't like Edward Kenway yeah he seems
kind of trophy like he was just gonna
like going
this is that dude I'm kind of
frustrating with the third game because
that character could have been something
and then kind of didn't ended up being
just another Sasson weirdo and a bit of
a shame Joshi played a bunch of us and
do you think you're gonna go back and
play some more Assassin's Creed
syndicate I I'd like to like kind of see
where it goes I've heard there's cool
parts that I have yet to see but I don't
know if I'll be able to do it right away
with all the other cool games coming up
and it's I wouldn't say it's very high
on my priority list
okay so many good games coming out at
the moment it was a cool game that it
just I don't know I got a lot of games
on my plate right yeah a lot of destiny
yeah rocket League yeah to play those
how many updates I'm gonna get
themselves expert that's month on that's
not fair you all real instruments I'm
cheating but best Assassin's Creed in
years Dan Alexa yeah I think it's the
best one since - oh wow really - it
reminds me of - yeah all right well
there you go 910 on GameSpot calm and be
sure to check out our review and that's
not what you think
yeah what's your favorite Assassin's
Creed game are you interested in
syndicate have you picked it up and what
do you think yourself please put your
thoughts in the comment box below we'll
be back here on the lobby Tuesday at 2
p.m. Pacific see you then
[Music]